All right, welcome to the Monday Zoom call.
I'll be taking today.
We had a few questions come in.
Not very many.
So hopefully you guys have some questions.
This is going to be fairly short.
A reminder to look at your member's site,
the homepage for what's new.
And the new thing that pertains to people on this call is going to be
that every one of our patients has full access.
And three access to our courses.
So look at our courses page currently.
We have four courses up.
Looks like this that link that you'll see on the homepage in green.
There this is courses see here or you go to our website.
Our main clinic website at the top.
You'll see courses.
And then you can click on click on that.
The genetics course should be up.
I thought it was going to be up Friday, but Justin has a few other things
you need to think about it.
Should be up today or tomorrow.
And so if you haven't had your genetics done,
you can look at the genetics course as well.
We have some questions on genetics right off the bat here,
but you can look at the other courses as well.
The access to the courses.
Is the same as your login to the member site, the same username,
your main email that you used to communicate with the clinic.
And the password that you created to get out of the member site should be the exact same.
Username and password.
So first questions on the right settings where they talk about essential oils,
the blood stimulating setting.
Where would you put those oils and do you have to use all of them?
So no, that was just a practitioner's protocol for blood stimulating.
So no, you don't need to use all of them.
And with any essential oils,
you want to make sure some oils are hot.
Some people are more sensitive.
They're skin is more sensitive to essential oils.
You certainly don't want to put essential oils directly on your skin and cause irritation.
You may have to use a carrier oil, but it's diluting it with a whole but oil or even all of the oil.
Some people skin art is not sensitive, but still it's good to change spots so you could put it.
On your chest, if you're dealing with.
Anything you could any condition you could put oils anywhere on your body.
If you're dealing with people like to mix oils together with a carrier oil and put it on their bottom of their feed before they go to bed.
And it had really good results.
So I suggest that you change the spots that you're putting essential oils.
If you're putting essential oils on your body on a daily basis irritation can build up over time.
So it's good to change locations where you're putting your essential oils maybe on your chest on your.
Your belly at different times on your feet at different times change it up so you don't end up developing some sort of sensitivity or irritation.
How do we do a genetic review what our tests are complete.
So make sure that you look at go back to the member site and look at the genetics page on the member site.
So how we're doing genetic reviews right now we're not doing individual reviews where we're going over the genetics individually one by one anymore we found that that is just not as effective because it's like drinking from a fire host.
So we've created several videos on the genetics home page.
That is the page on your member site that's listed tab is genetics and genetic review.
Go back to that there is a full genetic review video so going through and going through a sample of the genes there's an older one of me going through a sample of the genes from a few years ago.
The genetic the entire genetics profile that will be sending you is over 200 pages long.
There's no way that you want anybody to go over all of those you won't remember a thing the next day.
So it's even if you're savvy genetics you need to kind of digest it slowly.
So we put together some videos that you can watch that you can pause that you can rewind that you can listen to again and again if you really want to get information on genetics.
Understand also that we have an entire genetics course that will be right here because you'll be able to click on and you can go through that entire course if you really want to nerd out on genetics.
I love genetics it's very fun it's very interesting it's correlative to cancer and correlative to other diseases knowing once genetics can be super helpful in.
You know helping prevent things helping protect yourself in different ways but genetics is not everything happy genetics is everything so it's really you could have the worst let's say phase one liver detox pathway genes but you could still you know none of them could really be affecting you and if you took care of yourself.
Epigenetically meaning environmentally and everything choices and everything those might not affect you at all and even though you have slow detox pathways the things that you're doing to take care of yourself.
Is is definitely overriding all your defects on your genetic pathway so watch so how do we do genetic review you're going to watch the videos that are on the genetic page.
We also send you what's called genetic summary so we'll summarize the genes and the defects and highlight the ones in yellow that you have either a lot of defects on or some that we might want to look at more in depth and in support from a nutritional.
Pathway nutritional idea and then also we send you a plan of action so we send you a summary and then we send you an action plan.
Most people all they need is that summary of an action plan because they can know what to do there's going to be a couple tweaks based upon that action plan.
Now almost always is a couple tweaks we might want to add something at a product or change the diet or tweak some different things that's all you need to do there's probably one two three four bullet points of changes that you need to make.
And you don't need to become a genetic specialist all you need to do is look at those bullet points but if you want to have more questions on your genes you can either a ask them in the general question.
In any of the general question forms on the zoom call and we will answer them either on the genetic Q&A zoom call which is a Tuesday at two or on this zoom call or on my Wednesday zoom call so I will answer them or and we'll answer those on any of those zoom call soon we're always here for you to ask questions.
But we're not here to turn you into a genetic specialist so you can certainly do or not any of the videos you want.
But we're not going to go gene by gene over your summary with you you can do that if you certainly want to.
Another question can I have not so so not so is a 11 flat bread.
But it also is it is still made of flour and it contains gluten so if you are supposed to be gluten free or it's recommended that you're gluten free then the answers no so if that is not an issue for you then certainly you can but not if you're supposed to be going gluten free.
I see in our cancer protocol that we should submit a follow up cheek swap sample for genetic testing every three months so first of all that's not correct you're not submitting a follow up cheek swap for genetic testing your.
It is recommended that you submit a follow up cheek swap in three months just for re checking for us to recheck any supplements is not for genetic testing.
Is this every three months after the results come back in so no so it's not every three months a lot of people never send in another cheek swap a lot of people send it as cheek swap even more regularly than three months I actually created a video on our member site on our website to
But on our member site is is on the cheek swap section of the site explains when should you get retested how should you think about that is that something you need to do some people don't do it at all like I said some people do it more regularly depending on how their health is doing some people if they're really doing well was typically other people that don't get rechecked.
Alright, how does the right work with parasites does it zap them like a zapper so the right works best on living organisms so if you're trying to kill bacteria if you try to kill a virus try to kill parasites that's what the right works best on the only caveat to that is that if you're not running if you're running the viral program and you have parasites it's going to do literally nothing to a parasite.
If you're running a specific parasite program but you have a different parasite it's not going to really do anything to that parasite the larger parasite like worms tapeworms round worms it's very difficult to really try to stimulate your immune system to kill those things you need to use anti parasitic herbs as well like wormwood and things like that but
but the single cell organisms that's where the rifle really works well so the multicell organisms the worms and things like that it's much more difficult than you need to use some other protocols as well.
When does weight loss become a concern i'm losing about two to three pounds per week week which i think is part of the detoxing it's nice but not a goal or trying to do will this balance out it's hard to tell so it becomes a problem if so a person once they change their diet okay let's say they despite that they have cancer they make some.
Pretty radical dietary changes it's pretty common that you're going to start losing weight it becomes a problem when it's like okay i am getting below a healthy weight that is that is a problem you don't want to be below a healthy weight for your height and body built.
If you're below a healthy weight for your height and body build you need to call on making a point with me because we cannot be losing two to three pounds a week that's just an absolute cannot let that happen so we want to make sure that.
That we're not in a state of cocaxia so cocaxia isn't weight loss because you made strict dietary changes in boy I did have about 25 pounds to lose so i'm kind of getting back to maybe my high school weight it actually feels good but i'm not even trying to do it cocaxia is like oh my gosh i'm actually below the you know any adult weight that i've ever had and i'm trying to eat as much as i can and i still am losing two to three pounds a week.
Healthy state to be in that's typically when your cancer is gobbling up all your nutrients if a person is in cocaxia meeting that they are losing two to three pounds a week and they're not at us they're already at or below normal healthy weight then we need to add other things to their diet we need you just absolutely the better.
You just have to add carbs back to your diet so we typically recommend more complex carbs to begin with.
Like oatmeal and sweet potatoes and twice baked white potatoes.
But you cannot be losing that kind of weight if you're at or below a healthy weight level so that's what it really depends on is if you're at or below healthy weight.
Gotta put the brakes on that weight loss.
Okay any other questions so just to reiterate remember when.
Your genetics are ready.
Then you'll get an email from us or either myself or and probably come from and or Angie's email and it will include your complete genetic report which is.
Well over 200 pages and it'll include your genetic summary and then your genetic action steps so most people only look at the summary and and look at the highlighted things on the summary or look at the action steps but that is explained thoroughly on the two videos on the genetic page so look at those two videos on the genetic page.
And you'll get an idea of what the next steps are and then you can jump on our our genetic zoom call it's I think the first and third Thursday of the month it's listed on the genetic page so that will help or you could ask your questions on these two zoom calls either one it's just fine so.
All right you know are there questions I thought this is a good verse for today listen to advice and acceptance instruction in the and you'll be wise course we need to be asking questions we need to be seeking for truth.
We need to be diligent in our studies certainly in our studies of the word show ourselves approved.
So that we're ready and season it out to answer questions and help people in their journey as well.
And remember that our journey no matter how difficult it is it has a purpose godly purpose and believe me God's purpose isn't just to glorify us on earth for us to have a wonderful life.
God's purpose is to mold us and shape us into the image from the sun so that we may spend eternity for him and with him and learning about him and that's really what our purpose is and and we need to just trust him all the things that happen in our life.
Trust that God has a greater purpose and we will not most likely be able to figure out or even some good knowledge up for others earth will know about it when we get to heaven.
And we'll spend eternity see his glory learning about him more and more in a daily basis and it's going to be glorious and this sliver of a sliver of a time that we spend others is nothing compared to eternity forever forever and ever and ever and ever.
Just glorifying him and learning about him it's going to be glorious doesn't mean we don't do our work and we spend time wisely here that's what we're supposed to do that's why you're here.
But we just keep in remembrance and ultimately the Lord's purpose will prevail.
All right, thanks for today and i'll see you Wednesday make sure you submit your questions on our zoom call.
Orb on our site and i love you all let me pray for everybody.